artificial intelligence and cows they're
not terms commonly spoken in the same
sentence but in the dairy industry that
is beginning to change
i'm here in dublin to meet a company
called canthus which develops an ai
system for dairy farmers and for whom
terms like facial recognition for cows
it's just another day in the office
so let's talk about farming a little bit
like when you're going to a farmer
how do you approach a farmer and say hey
we've got artificial intelligence we've
got cameras that we can install in your
barns when you point out that we have
the ability to to take a camera like
this and watch their cows
24 hours a day every minute of the day
we're able to use this to watch the
behaviors of the cows what they spend
their time doing and also the availables
you feed that's just a very powerful
idea for farmer that realizes well wait
i'm not making assumptions i'm not
trying to presume what my cows do at two
o'clock in the morning or how they're
being fed by my employees i actually can
do it with a camera
one thing i'm particularly curious about
is what the camera sees
what the software sees so here is 24
hours
on a farm but what we can see here is
the output of our computer vision models
where we're identifying or observing
every cow that we see as well as the
different activities that they're
engaged in so you can see that by the
color of the box
and so here's another time lapse video
of a day on the farm and here we're
focusing on the feed this is the output
of our computer vision model so we have
a segmentation model that identifies for
every pixel in the image if that pixel
contains feed or not it's a it's an
interesting problem to solve from a
computer vision perspective
so this is what the farmer sees when
they first sign in so the farm dashboard
gives
a glance or a snapshot of everything on
the farm that we measure in some high
level performance kpis
so under her productivity for instance
standing time when they're standing so
this is when they're standing in the
alley or standing at the beds
this is generally unproductive time we
don't want them to be
bearing their weight or standing for
excessive amounts of time so if we have
increasing standing time that's
generally a bad indicator on the farm
but if we have increasing lying time
cows are efficiently getting into their
beds lying that's time when they spend
turning the feed that they're eating
into
milk
what the technologies allow is less
intervention with cows and or smarter
intervention with cows they they can
choose when they want to get milked they
can choose when they want to eat a and
they can choose when they want to sleep
so
cantus and the cameras will see the
animals as a herd and and
with the health index and the laying
down and the eating it'll tell you
what's going on with that group of
animals and what a what needs to change
to make them feel better it's very
a cutting edge technology and ultimately
you can make better decisions because of
that
a topic that keeps coming up is cow
comfort historically
how the cow comfort index was used in
practice was mostly in a research or
academic setting and then if you wanted
to look at it on a farm you would have
to go out to every pen and manually
count and note down and you would get a
single measurement and you would get it
as often as you are willing to get it
which you know in practice wouldn't be
very often but now this is something
that we are measuring every day and
that's what we're providing to customers
is
things that we can measure
in order to manage welfare and in order
to improve cow comfort and cal welfare
on the farm
this is
the most necessary thing you need to do
today the values i measure are their
longevity cows are living longer cows
are having more productive life and
they're having less health events and
that to me is a happier cow so a happier
cow is a healthier cow in my world and
today we have healthier cows than we've
ever had